uh so this is the one slide i get to
reuse and on all of the talks that i
give
it's a little bit of an intro talk i
already got a nice intro so i probably
don't need to spend too much time here a
few things the first one being
you know i've been doing data for quite
a while now so i feel like i've seen
you know uh generational shifts and i've
seen people kind of reinvent things that
were already invented by previous
generations of engineers just kind of
interesting place to sit
um i've also seen like
you know kind of like expansion cycles
and like kind of things like going
monolith and going kind of more um
cambrian explosion i think we're in one
of these phases so i'll talk about that
today
uh more recently too i started a company
so i decided to leave the big tech
companies and and go start my own thing
which has been
a super fun ride uh and the tiny little
commercial bit of this talk is just
mentioning that
preset is essentially apache superset
managed as a service we have a large
freemium tier so i encourage people if
you have not tried the apache superset
or first like what is apache superset
that's a superset is a data
visualization and
exploration dashboarding platforms it's
very much a bi tool i also have to wave
a little bit of a
bias flag saying that
i'm talking about the next generation of
business intelligence and like my
vantage point and my position is like
very very tied to the work that we've
done around superset so as i speak about
next generation like of course it's
biased by the work that i've done and
the work that i've done is biased by my
vision so i just wanted to be upfront on
that
and then
preset so preset is like manage hosted
uh apache superset large free tier pay
as you go no bs uh you know just kind of
easy to set up
the ida just works and it's open source
so i encourage you if you have not tried
apache superset
i have not tried it in the past few
months to go and check it out because
we've made covered a lot of grounds
over the past few
months all right so the flow of this
talk
so i'm going to be talking about the
story of bi kind of how we got here so i
think it's always good when we talk
about the future of something to
understand where we came from
and then i'm going to talk about some of
the components or ideas around this next
generation
so that includes
ideas like enabling analytics everywhere
the delamination of the stack
open source gonna what is the role of
open source in next generation
data platforms and around vi
um the evolving role of the database you
know in regards to bi as well as talking
about semantic layers i was just in a
conversation with one of the attendees
here like getting started to get deep
into like where what is the semantic
layer and like where does it live and
how is it eroding so it's really
interesting topic
that i'll be scratching the surface of
and then um i have a bucket for all the
things that uh i'm not really talking
about but i want to mention so
let's jump into it so first i wanted to
define business intelligence but like i
hate the term personally so i hate that
my talk title
is the next generation business
intelligence but at the same time if you
talk about something i think it's such a
well-established
concept
that i think it makes sense to anchor on
it
the reason why i don't like the term is
like individually these words
uh kind of kind of trigger a gag reflex
for me like just the the term like i
think analytics are they can cover and
solve problems like way beyond in
business
uh and intelligence it's just like you
think about the cia and intelligence in
that way that's like what are you using
this intelligence to do
so
i think maybe the first
idea around the next generation is the
naturalization of business intelligence
won't be called business intelligence so
and what are the alternative words that
people should use to talk about this is
things like
the data consumption layer uh the data
data visualization data exploration
um
as a and you know i think in general too
like business intelligence which is very
monolithic this is just like one
solution that covers a lot of use cases
and i think like in the modern data
stack we're breaking down things and we
should talk about the components of a bi
tool as opposed to bi which is a big
loaded con like too too wide of a
concept and maybe uh ungrounded kind of
too large of an umbrella
so the brief brief story of bis i don't
want to go too deep into that but at the
same time i think it's good to
checkpoint and see where business
intelligence coming from um
so if you felt like me that the term
business intelligence sounds old and
crusty uh
you know you were right and and then
maybe you didn't know how right you were
where you know it goes back to uh
you know uh
1865 so it's been quite a while since
this idea or the term at least has been
used
more recently so if you think about it
like contemporary bi
um is probably seated or rooted around
you know ibm in 1858 so
uh
not new ideas of course uh you know
we're pretty far at that time of what
you know business intelligence what you
know what it came to be
but here i wanted to go quickly
and do a quick uh history of decay of
the different decades and what we've
seen of course this is super super
shallow so
and that's the intention here so the 70s
we've seen like ibm and sibo they kind
of identify a business opportunity here
uh i think it was really anchored on
like competitive analytics
for large businesses
in the eight in the 80s we've seen the
emergence of the data warehouse so like
early on it's like oracle
and some databases there and then the
notion of a data warehouse was
established in the 90s the the books
about data warehousing were
so we started to see the emergence of
best practices so the grandfather of the
grandfathers of data warehousing wrote
their book so ralph kimball
bill and men wrote books about data
warehouses
and we started to see vendors appear
vendors like hyperion
who were building very specialized
tooling
uh for specialists so super early on
you know specialized tooling i think in
the 2000 the next challenge that we've
seen is like we really index or maybe
over index and this idea of self-service
so the
the promise there and the interest was
to say
you're going to have a small group of
people data specialists within
uh when an organization and typically
i've had those titles i've been that
person so i was the data warehouse
architect and the business intelligence
engineer and the role there was the
general idea is to use tools
to to say create your data warehouse
build it and then build this heavy
semantic layer that in theory helps
people self-serve at least that's the
promise or the idea there is that you
would be able to
build the layers so that people can come
and assemble their own reports dashboard
answer their own question
i'm not sure if i think we kind of
failed on delivering on that promise for
a variety of reasons i might not uh get
too deep into here today but maybe we'll
save that for office hours
um in the 2010 so i didn't want to go
too deep into that i think like everyone
here um it's close enough that you kind
of know what happened
i didn't want to get into the birth and
and struggles and and maybe ultimately
death of the hadoop elephant
but but i think the big themes for 2010
are things like data going mainstream uh
the explosion of specialized tools
democratization of access to data
specialization of roles right all of us
are data practitioners
uh and i think we've made like tons of
progress in the 2000s and
now or soon we're going to get to talk
about kind of where we're at and what's
in what's ahead
all right so some statements so there
are some things that i wanted to say
that didn't really fit you know into
like the past or the future so maybe
that's more of the present
those are like just statements of things
that are
interesting about business intelligence
the first one
is the eye is kind of unique where
it's it's trying to be kind of
everything for everyone
it works for all types of data it works
for every persona they've worked it
should work for
every workflow right and i'm not sure if
it's realistic at least like modern
product building is more like you
identify some personas some use cases
and you build tools for them
but i think in bi we've had like two or
three decades of like training people of
like
there's something that solves kind of
everything data and buyers and sellers
i've been trained to
uh to kind of expect that
yet even though like one tool should do
it all
we see
we see that yet like most companies have
multiple bi tools i think there's
something that proves that you know a
single tool probably won't work for
everyone
um behind so you know there's people
talking about no code i don't know if
there's any talks at this conference
about no code but something that's
interesting is uh
bi is the original kind of no code so 20
years ago
we had like really fancy and advanced
guise to build
dashboards that's where essentially like
simple data apps so i think like bi
maybe is ahead of its time there's some
interesting question like why
is bi so
naturally inclined for
gooeys i think the answer there is
pretty is pretty simple is the fact that
if you're going to build something like
highly kind of layout spatial and um
and visual like that's probably best
done in a gooey tool you can start to
imagine photoshop headless so there's
some there's some good like kind of
questions and
uh
and assumptions around that
um bi and another fact that's
interesting about bi is that it is at
the end of the analytics process chain
value chain and this chain as we all
know here as practitioners is a chain
that's like very kind of intricate and
long so that means that
bi being the last link in that chain if
there's any problems you know up up the
stack or up or down the stack or
up the chain uh it's well seen so for
the value proposition of bi to realize
itself it requires that you know kind of
everything and that chain works well
it's just kind of it can be a tough
tough place to be right you buy a bi
tool like why is it not working well
there's there's a few links that are
missing or broken your chain
and then like an idea i bring in my
talks is uh i think that's changing too
because the work we're doing all of us
but you know there's this assumption
that data should be simple it's like i
hired my first like data engineer last
week like why is this not all working
and fixed uh where in software
engineering it's like very well accepted
that you're going to need like a variety
of tools and systems and services and
people like you know different varieties
of software engineers that's super well
accepted in the data space you're like
hey i've got my analysts i've got my
data engineer like why isn't like data
solved for my company so i think that's
something collectively we need to change
and i think that's already changing
quite a bit
all right so this is where i get to
start talking about the future because
this talks about the next generation of
the previous generation and so far i
haven't talked about any of the
uh the future um kind of forward
thinking things
so first thing i think like you see a
lot of people talking about data apps uh
so i think like
try to to explain this this slide uh the
general idea with this slide is that
i think we've been
uh like for a while we've been like
hoarding data into our data warehouse
gonna bring all the data in the
warehouse putting a bi tool on top of it
and gonna that's our little sandbox in
place to do things
and
i think that works for many things but i
think that fails at in context analytics
which is you know the best place to
consume the data and interact with data
is probably within the context in which
it exists and live and it's generated
so i think we're gonna see
like kind of interactive data
visualization and analytics come out of
the bi tool and be part of all of the
apps and products that you use every day
so
every that's already happening i think
every sas product every app is slowly
becoming also a data app or there's an
analytics dimension so if you think
about your applicant tracking system
your crm
uh you know all the the hundreds of sas
tools like you know if you use things
like
datadog or github there's like always an
insights tab somewhere that's
interactive
and i think like this is not as a an
alternative to the data hoarding and
data warehousing type approach i think
there's still like tons of value in data
hoarding and bringing all of your data
from all your systems
you know to your data warehouse because
data is most valuable when it's like
extended and in context and enriched
but if every one of your sas tools and
product you use every day had an
interactive analytics view that was rich
then the need for hoarding and doing all
that work that's expensive and brittle
and hard would not be as required so i
think it's complementary there's some
ideas be like
of that that relate to uh the term data
mesh but not the concept and you know so
i'm not much of a disciple of the data
mesh
you know story or publications we've had
so far but if you think of your data
living everywhere on the cloud i think
having different kind of windows into
that and having bi-directional sync like
make it easy to bring your data to your
warehouse but also to do reverse ctl so
data is kind of everywhere and then you
can have different port holes or
viewpoints on top of your data
so
what what is to remember from this slide
i think is a
pretty uh it's the idea of like data
apps i think and that we need to take
interactive analytics out the bi tool
and bring them to the tools and products
you use every day
so headless bi so there are a lot of
terms in the modern data stack that are
slightly defined based on like but more
by marketing people than practitioners
so we have to be cautious with that and
headless bi is probably one of these
terms um i i have
first like let me let me explain or just
kind of define it
from my point of view so
um maybe one grounding or good way to
think about this is
headless linux right so you can install
linux for a server uh without the gui or
you can install the gui if you want so
it's kind of
you know it's a pet option also you want
to use a gui or you don't want to use a
gui so essentially it's just software
that works without a gui as a headless
software
you know what's interesting about
headless in bi so first
you know i said earlier that guys are
kind of natural and good in the data
visualization dashboarding space right
just because it's so visual and like the
fact that it was invented 20 years ago
that we first built guise for that kind
of tells the story of
guise makes sense for data
um but i think headless has other
promises that are really good and you'll
see like tristan at dbt labs talk about
that i think just a lot of people saying
like and you know i'm behind that
movement with like airflow is all about
pipeline as code like pipeline x codes
are more powerful than pipeline and
guise
because when
workflows or pipeline are expressed as
code they can be version you can tie ci
cd so continuous improve continuous
delivery kind of continuous integration
on top of it so i think like the
benefits that come from managing assets
as code
still apply in bi
and uh what's
what's really the statement here that i
want to that i want to try to emphasize
and make is that what we need is
bi-directional flows that allow to go
maybe gui first and kind of eject into
code and then get the benefits of
managing cert like the assets you want
to manage as code s code or you can
maybe manage things as code and eject
into a gui and then derive the data sets
and do what you do in a gui so we need
these bi-directional flow
i think
i don't think it's going to be like
everyone moving to like all sudden like
that gui is dead and everyone does
headless bi and that's the primary
solution for everyone it's more like
some data sets that are more visible
more used you need more rigor things
like continuous improve
integration and continuous deployment
you would take these data sets in
certain area and manage them as code
when uh when you need so
in that regard you know superset is very
much like that where if you want to
be
using managing your assets as code you
can do that if you manage them in gui so
you have this this idea of a
bi-directional flow between the two
all right enough about headless bi um
all right so that's a big trend this one
the the the delamination of the stack i
hinted on that already a few times
um
it's this idea that bi tools things like
business object microstrategy
even even looker and like tableau they
want to be monolithic like they want to
be like you buy a bi tool you get all
the stuff that you need it's just like
this cohesive platform that solves
everything
and
then what we see with the modern data
stack is that we're breaking down
the the stack into layers that are more
loosely coupled and play well together
so this is already happening
uh quite a bit i think i got some some
good slide that kind of showed that
visually
maybe we over indexed uh on that and i
think that's from two slides from like
this is kind of like the stupidity of
like
you know like all of the butter did a
stack and there's some ai stuff in there
but you know you could have a team of
like 10 people
um you know work for an entire quarter
to just figure out what the right stack
is here like you know the another call
like we're going to use this would this
one or that one and by the way we are
here like like we're gonna somewhere in
the sea of uh
of solutions uh so it's like there it's
like um
selection paralysis right like too much
choice is kind of an issue
um going back to
this um
i i hate this uh this magic quadrant
with a passion
uh
four reasons that i will explain
hopefully you will relate to
the first one the first thing i want to
talk about so i want to show this slide
not because it's relevant but because
it's wrong and flawed in in deep ways
that are really interesting
so completeness of vision
is the x-axis is very important access
they want to qualify things on complete
so that assumes that monoliths are great
like i think i think what gartner is
implying is that the more to the right
that you go the better right but the
reality is that if you look at startup
economics
the completeness of vision
reversely correlates to your ability to
execute so if you have a small team
focused on a specific use case they can
build something really great and really
good
if you're trying to be checked of all
trade
you know you're not going to be great at
everything so i think like the way to
think about this is flawed i think in
the uh especially cast in the light of
the modern data stack where
where we're trying to delaminate and
have like a collection of tools that are
really good at a
set of things and are loosely coupled
and work well together i think to me
this vision for the future of having
uh you know open source tooling
commercial open source companies adding
um you know like companies are really
good at a handful of things and being
able to pick and choose and and glue the
stuff together
is a much better version of the future
than the microsoft future
uh you know where you're kind of super
locked in and uh
and yeah i i don't want to even like
think about you know what that means in
terms of like
you know uh what it means for your daily
team your culture
um so out of this the good news is like
this is kind of super confusing and a
huge mess but like order is starting to
emerge from this so this is from uh my
my uh great uh friends and deep pockets
people at andreessen are with so they
did a bunch of analysis on the modern
data stack and this is one of the slides
that they came up with to try to make
sense of like what are the swim lanes
that exist
what are the different kind of cells or
sub-components in those lanes and how do
these
things
kind of relate to one another and this
is published i think they published a
new version of it today i was like one
of the many many people they interviewed
to try to make sense of of all this
nonsense here
and i think in that world you get to
kind of pick and choose what you like
and you get to evolve you know and as
clear winners emerge or like you know as
maybe it's like a fit thing like for you
you're like oh i really you know
airflow really works for us or dbt
really works for us or a combination of
the two really works for us then you're
still allowed to go and pick things and
kind of create and assemble your your
own stack
so
like order emerging from this uh
essentially like loosely coupled
uh approach to thing there's no like
here i'm not advocating that loosely
coupled is always better you know it's
just in this case in this era
where you know we started from monolith
and we went all the way through like an
expansion phase that's really confusing
to all of us um that you know i think
this is a better version of the future
that's where we're going but it's like
that's you know the vision i'm building
towards personally you know
um so this slide is trying to say to
look at like if you if you really you
look at the core of bi you take like
this this like fuzz ball and you start
removing all the things that maybe don't
really belong there um what's left in
the end so to me at the very core of it
is data exploration visualization
assembling collection of visualization
is the next natural steps that's
building dashboards assembling dashboard
making them interactive
sql seems like
you know your your your kids and
grandkids are probably gonna like some
of them are gonna learn sql uh and not
as like the same way that you know some
of you might have learned cobol and
fortran i think like sequel is here to
stay
uh it is the lingua franco of data it's
super well established
so that means like tooling
uh that do exploration visualization
dashboard should like kind of understand
sql like uh at least like use it in
places so that if you do speak sql you
can do more advanced things
and then the more i think interesting
statement here
and maybe the one that's like a little
bit more
forward looking is
allowing people to create interactive
data apps with the building blocks of
the bi tool so if the bi tool
is made out of set of components and
libraries and services
i think the bi tool of the future
allows you to remix and repackage these
services and components to create your
own
data apps or data experiences
and why so one version of future might
be you know you have a bi tool and then
you have libraries to help you build
data apps and these things are
disjointed and they're different uh i
think that exists today um i think
certainly like you know that
makes sense in some ways i think like
there's there's some really powerful
thing that happens if
uh
there's kind of a link between the two
or if the the bi platform in the future
if it can also be
um you know you can use the components
the services of that platform to build
other things and to remix it you get
some really good synergies there
uh why you know i talked already about
like the no code to low code to full
code and bidirectional flow between the
two so that means like you might be able
to build something in a gui
uh build a dashboard embed it and then
eventually kind of eject it as code use
sub components of it change the layout
and code
and then kind of take control so over
like maybe at the beginning you have a
kind of gui one size fits all experience
but you can grow into a more
customized and integrated experience
with your product
i'm not sure if i lust most the people
here but uh
i think it's an interesting idea right
the question is like should the bi tool
be the
uh be also the platform to build data
apps and i believe so and that's what
we're building you know
in the super set community and i preset
the future is full of open source that
well actually the present is full of
open source i wrote this blog post a
while ago so it looks like uh last year
so it's out there if you guys are
interested to
uh to kind of dig deeper in this idea
but like the general idea of the blog
post is
looking at um the mod the data stack
that we have
uh how much of it is open source and
then why it's open source
and do the reason why it's open source
apply as you go up the stack into bi and
the answer is yes like it's clear like
people love open source because there's
no lock in
you're able to extend
you're able to integrate you have the
power the community all these things
that are super valid for infrastructure
also apply
um to to business intelligence tool and
tools that are more in the gui world
also if the
the premise on the previous slide was
that it's the same tool that is the
platform to build data apps as the tool
who uh you use for a business intel more
traditional internal business
intelligence then that means that uh you
if you're building on top of a platform
you want that platform to be open that's
just like a premise nowadays like you
wouldn't want to build like an ibm
message queue to to build your own data
infrastructure you want to use kafka
right because you know you don't want
for ibm to kind of own you
all right uh i don't know what i'm doing
on time so i will do a quick check to
see how deep i can go in this chunks i'm
30 minutes in that means i've got 10.
okay i think that's good so i'll be able
to to go like somewhat deep in the
semantic layer so first i think i need
to establish like what is the semantic
layer it's kind of a term that was
more hot or more known in business
intelligence in the 2000s
and
so our semantic layer
and trying to explain it it's a little
bit of a prism
that um
that lives under your bi tool that uh
knows about your physical database and
it knows extra semantics that can enable
people to self-serve and create their
own
reports dashboard data visualization so
it's an abstraction
that enriches really your physical
data structures
to for the purpose of cell service so i
know i said that twice but it's a little
hard to make sense of um
yeah so so so the semantic layer is kind
of a heavy construct
um and maybe i'll go into the next slide
i feel like i had so much more to say on
that before jumping to the next slide
but i think i'll get to it so um
so i think there's a case for a thin
semantic layer so this semantic layer
exists like there's all sorts of
semantics about your data some of it
live in your database some of it live on
your transformation layer
some of it live on the chart that you're
building itself
but what's happening with a thick
semantic layer things like and by that
like i mean things like lookers look ml
historically business object universes
microstrategy projects so for for people
that have maybe more gray hair like you
know what it will like resonate um
so this semantic layer typically lives
inside a bi tool it's kind of hard to
make so so you know you all know as
practitioners that
uh change management and data is hard
right like so you're evolving your
pipelines you're evolving your data
structures and you're evolving your data
your data itself
um that's challenging already as is you
know change manager management huge
burden and hard for data engineers
if on top of that you have some sort of
like semantic layer that that is like
tightly coupled with the change it just
becomes really hard to
keep and manage and sync this extra
layer so that means like now on top of
knowing you know airflow dbt sql
you know data set data modeling you also
need to understand like things like look
ml and the subtleties of it and how it
relates to the rest of the stuff so you
know you have a tower that's pretty
shaky at the top it's really heavy or
like a shane a chain that's pretty weak
with like weak links and then you're
trying to add this like extra layer of
complexity on top and it's uh
you know it's a it's a challenge to say
the the least there's also um the lack
of a universal semantic layers there's
something i was talking about with uh
someone like just before getting into
the talk but um so if you do it if
you're like i'm gonna pay the cost i
want to really enable
self-service i'm going to do that i'm
going to invest a lot in look ml
if you've chosen looker what happens is
like when you bring in you know superset
or tableau or whatever other tool then
you need to do that all over again
because like so most companies use
multiple bi tools and then there's no
universal semantic layer so you need to
duplicate that logic and manage it as
challenging to say the least so
um
personally i'm advocating for bringing a
lot of these semantics down a layer into
the transform layer that's a better
place for a lot of semantics to exist
and that means that those semantics can
be shared on all on all the tools also
advocate for like dataset centric data
modeling which basically says like
the interface for most of the tools and
the humans using
data sets to answer questions in your
organization should be based on simple
data sets that are
easy to reason about
and then that means that a lot of
semantics on how to join the data and
which metrics is really to which
dimension exists inside the data sets
construct
things like metric definition should
probably be coupled with the data set
not the semantical area itself
so the question is like that we don't
need a semantic layer is like where
should that logic and semantics where
should they live
um
yeah i think there's maybe another thing
or two i want to mention there too is
that semantic layer is like expensive to
manage and a lot of in other cases you
do analytics there's a lot of like
you're pushing the edge of discovery
with your data and you the data sets are
not mature they're not settled so it
sucks to have to build the semantic
layer up front and to have this rigor
around labels and descriptions and like
you know add this all kind of layer
complexity when you're just kind of
playing around so i think like a
point being a progressively adoptable
semantic layer is is best especially in
new areas so you have different subject
area different teams a different level
maturity of different data sets and
it's good to enable the semantic layer
to
grow as the as the team or as data sets
or subject areas are becoming more
covered
i think the self-service has failed at
delivering on its promises that's kind
of a big statement so if you build that
semantic layer the premise is like
people can now come and self-serve um
there's an interesting analogy
i've been jumping i'm jumping all over
the place but people have been using the
restaurant analogy for the data
warehouse for quite a bit like i don't
know if can you show a hands of people
have heard that comparison in the past
it seems to be like not that popular of
an idea but general idea says like oh if
the data warehouse the restaurant the
semantic layer is the menu for the
restaurant
but there's something in the modern
uh one thing i talked about on pushing
this restaurant analogy in the past is
that
if the data warehouse is a restaurant
then it should be it's becoming more of
a buffet where you come in you know data
scientists come in the data analysts are
engineers and people just like i'm not
going to take the menu i'm just going to
go and pick the data that i need and
assemble my meal there's also like
people go to raw ingredients in the back
room you know they're like i'm going to
take some raw ingredients make my own
thing this is more the reality it's a
big like costco kind of big open market
that's super messy uh and the menu and
that context is not that useful
um
yeah i think you know there's some
there's something there that's like if
you
let's say if i drop you into um
a looker type interface and i'm like
okay you can go and self-serve now
you're still like gonna be if you're not
a practitioner and you don't have the
tribal knowledge you're still gonna be
like i kind of want my analysts to be
close to me while i drag and drop stuff
to know whether i'm making mistakes or
not so i think that's part of the reason
why semantic layers have
failed delivering on their promises so
you do all this work and it's not that
helpful it's heavy it can't be reused
you know
um so the evolving role of database is
one i'm kind of interested in so one
thing is like some bi vendors in the
past had storage engine you know tableau
has extracts so you can load your data
into your bi tool i think that's dead
you know people invest in big data
warehouses and things like snowflake big
query uh or you know accelerated tears
things like pinot
druid you know click house
and um
we want the vi tool to be a thin layer
over the data
over the data warehouse right you want
to do all the heavy lifting in that big
distributed in-memory cloud database
so i think we're going to see you know
tight coupling or like data bi vendors
won't make databases or extracts in the
future
um all that board codes are kind of
backed in action so the old app
workloads are workload like a tera genus
workload that are um analytical in
nature big scans like column store like
very good for column store and stuff
like that um database vendors are
working on that
loose coupling between the database and
visualization tool that's like i
mentioned that already
more semantics and the database itself i
think is a very interesting idea your
labels and description metric definition
maybe your database should be aware of
that stuff also
semantics about transformation if your
database is aware of all of the data
lineage it can
maybe figure out what is the best data
set to query to answer the the question
that you're trying to answer um that is
a feature of semantic layers called
aggregate awareness it's like oh there's
these two data set one is more
aggregated than the other and if you
depend on the query you run it wires the
query to the right the to the sim the
smaller data set
um so that was like something i had from
before that's a little bit of dbt config
i don't know if who here is like writes
dbt but eventually we would let we would
love to
define materialization based on database
uh usage i think that's something that's
going to come up in the future as well
okay so i think this is one of my last
slides i think i'm kind of good on time
here so some things that are half big
some ideas that people are throwing
around talking about the future of you
know data visualization and business
intelligence that i wanted to mention
um the reports that dashboards are dead
are greatly access like you know ahead
of their time i think if they're if
dashboards are dying i want a dashboard
to see how much they are dying you know
um so
so i think like even even if it's like
the analysis automation and bots and uh
ai's doing kind of the work that we do
here you know replacing us we'd still
want to see a dashboard on how how much
the bots are doing better than us
you know and making sure the bots are
working well so i think like dashboards
dashboards and visualization it's still
the the human
uh kind of data interface and you know
we're going to need that for as long as
we're curious about understanding uh the
the natural world
um
real time is kind of there's a question
like everything's going to become real
time uh and then all the charts are
going to kind of move dynamically and
everything's real time and you know
batches dead is also like not quite
happening yet i don't know if it's ever
going to happen
augmented analytics analysis automation
i should have had like a big portion of
my talk on that that's a super
interesting idea i'm really excited
about that it's still kind of not quite
there yet so that by that i mean like
root cause analysis anomaly detection
kind of automating the work of an
analyst
or at least like providing tools for
analysts to support their common use
cases is a really interesting area that
we haven't seen a lot
on just yet or at least i haven't seen
it i tried to build some of this stuff
in the past is really difficult
to build
let's see trustworthy centralized
unlimited data data metadata so that's
the amundsen data hub type thing i think
we're seeing some really good progress
on that's really exciting is this idea
too that
the discovery part of the bi tool
finding the charts and reports in
dashboard metadata that is interesting
to you
is moving out of bi and into data into
things like data hub and that relieves
the bi tool to really focus on
visualization exploration so that's
still kind of happening and interesting
uh collaborative workflows are on data
so the reality is that we all
collaborate on data data visualization
but we all do it in slack i don't know
if that's what you're experiencing too
but people take screenshots of whatever
dashboard and then go and slack like
check this out like send me the link i'm
gonna you know
uh save save a copy of your thing and
then show we show you um my version of
it so maybe that's okay that
collaboration are not taking place in
tools and into slacks
but i think we have yet to see really
good integrations there and really good
way to annotate and then see each
other's kind of insight label the data
and say like ah this
you know this dip is from this tsunami
that happened you know on that date
um
yes so the last one is the opening
statement and the really the thing the
problem i'm really interested in too and
the people at preset are working on and
something that's
like really in our day and age and like
as i'm talking to a group of people we
work closely with data i think we all
want to go and build like data
experiences and data apps
and i think we have yet to see like a
full comprehensive platform of all the
dream
components and tools and libraries and
services that we need to enable us to go
and build
awesome data apps and experiences so
really interested in this one like next
time i'll give a talk it will be to show
kind of progress that we've made
in those areas and with that uh last
last statement is one that i kind of
open with which is
uh if you haven't checked out apache
superset in a while check it out like
we've done so much work as a community
to bring it where it's at today
uh just in the past six months it has
gotten so much
uh more beautiful and better and more
like you know kind of usability has like
has gone uh
up quite a bit so i encourage you to
check it out and the best way to check
it out is on preset there's a free tier
so you can kind of play with it and see
what you think and with that that's all
folks